my name is matt walsh i am a children's
author and i've written a book called
johnny the walrus this book is all about
identity and imagination i'm johnny the
walrus he said with a roar the wood
floor is my ocean the carpet's my shore
he's swimming around like a walrus isn't
that silly and mommy was told to take
john to the zoo now she's going to take
her son to go live at the zoo like he's
a real wally i don't want to live
the zookeeper thought what's she talking
about
ma'am that's just a boy with wood spoons
in his mouth now he's the voice of
reason
[Music]
out of all the headlines to come out of
the events of this past weekend this is
surely my favorite from the independent
it reads
right wing blogger launches gofundme for
aoc's puerto rico grandmother in latest
personal attack
actually let me correct myself that's
not my favorite headline of the weekend
it's my favorite headline possibly of
all time and i feel that way even though
it misgenders me as a blogger which i'm
not by the way
not anymore i launched a gofundme
campaign
to repair and save abuela's home
if aoc is not going to help her family
members and is going to wait around for
the government to fix the problem then i
felt it had fallen to me
to do what aoc would not or could not do
the fundraiser marched on i wasn't doing
this for personal accolades
i was only partially doing it for
personal accolades
mainly it was about saving abuela's home
and we made stunning progress in that
regard in the space of just a few hours
many prominent people in right-wing
media including all of the hosts here at
the daily wire as well as stephen
crowder and dave rubin and others all
join the effort and in this space of 10
hours
get this
we raised 100 000
in 10 hours we were arguably
the most successful charity troll
campaign of all time
it also might have been the only charity
troll campaign of all time
[Music]
you and the school board have decided
that our kids should go to school all
day every day wearing muzzles like rabid
dogs i have listened to your arguments
and i've noticed that they're missing a
few things namely evidence data science
common sense and basic human decency
you presented no facts at all uh so let
me do that now here they are covet poses
almost no risk to our kids at all 4.2
million children have tested positive
for covid a total of
0.008 percent of them have died what
about the flu the cdc estimates that 480
kids died from the flu in the 2018-2019
season that's more than have died from
covid in a year and a half now did
anyone on this board suggest at any
point that year that kids wear masks did
anyone in this room suggest that at any
point anyone wear masks for flu which
again is more dangerous to kids than
covid that's a fact
now
do any of you know what sort of
psychological damage we do to children
by forcing them to cover their faces
teaching them that the air is toxic that
everyone around them is sick
depriving them of the ability to see
each other's faces do you know what kind
of damage that that does have you
thought about it
have you wondered about the health
effects of forcing kids to breathe
through sweat and spit and dirt soaked
rags every single day are you sure that
there are no health risks do you know
what the effect is on children
developmentally
if they're not able to read each other's
facial cues what about learning to read
and they can't see the teacher
enunciating the words
what does it do to a child's developing
immune system if he has to wear a mask
all day every day you're satisfied to
place this burden on children anyway and
why it's not to keep them safe they are
safe
it's not to keep the adults safe they
can all get vaccinated if they want no
you do it to make yourselves feel better
and to protect yourselves politically
the child's mask is a symbolic security
blanket for you not them
it's a disgrace and you should all be
ashamed thank you for your time
[Applause]
you know that guy raises some good
points
and uh pretty good looking guy too if i
have to if i do say so myself
no generation of kids in history
has ever faced anything like this never
has there been this concerted
coordinated far-reaching effort to
deprive them of that which is most basic
themselves and that's why we're here
today because we're not going to sit in
silence while our kids while any kids
are ripped to shreds by these damned
vultures these monsters
we are parents who care about our
children and not just our own children
but all children and we're not going to
abandon them to be brainwashed and
abused by a morally and intellectually
corrupted education system
if you're on the other side of this if
you're in the opposition and that scares
you
then i'm glad that it does if we have
you worried then good you should be
because we're not going away that's not
going to happen
this is just history in the making matt
walsh is bringing a lot of people over
here getting people finally brave enough
to stand and say no more to what the
school board is doing to our children's
futures this is the line in the sand
that we have drawn we're not going to
surrender our kids
to this darkness we're not going to do
it we're not going to give up on truth
not now not ever
thank you all i appreciate it thank you
god bless
i would thank you all for allowing me to
speak to you tonight but you try not to
allow it yet here i am now you only give
us 60 seconds so let me get to the point
you are all child abusers you prey upon
impressionable children and indoctrinate
them into your insane ideological cult a
cult which holds many fanatical views
but none so deranged as the idea that
boys are girls and girls or boys by
imposing this vile nonsense on students
to the point even of forcing young girls
to share locker rooms with boys you
deprive these kids of safety and privacy
and something more fundamental too which
is truth if education is not grounded in
truth then it is worthless worse it is
poison you are poison you are predators
i can see why you try to stop us from
speaking you know that your ideas are
indefensible you silence the opposing
side because you have no argument you
can only hide under your beds like
pathetic little gutless cowards hoping
we shut up and go away but we won't
i promise you that
thank you for your time and i'll talk to
you again very very soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i want to be here hey can anyone tell me
what a woman is that was my challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my choice
[Applause]
[Music]
so please everyone stop walking around
in public looking like hideous unbathed
ogres
my sweet babies
also you're all canceled there was
something so unnatural about hearing
matt utter the words my sweet babies
anthony says matt calling all of us
sweet babies gave me ptsd
but then another comment says okay so
matt's fan base is officially known as
the sweet baby gang
i
i i guess i can't really tell anyone
else how to identify themselves if you
want to be the sweet baby gang you can
be yeah you know what let's go with that
just to just to really confuse everybody
who doesn't listen to the show
hearing people who are fans of the show
identify themselves as a sweet baby gang
and the agreement we have to make is
that we never explain to anyone where
that
comes from or why
now matt
i am told that the sweet baby gang
has a special name for you they do they
do
sweet daddy walsh
my official name daddy walsh do you
expect to be addressed likewise by all
of you
yes daddy
[Music]